never forget this is the fight of a
lifetime for blissful klarsfeld
icon of anti nazi activism at
almost seventy eight years old she was
the distinguished guest of the ceremony for
the day of remembrance of the holocaust
at the european parliament always animated
by  'a great will problem of
nazi criminals ended of course
because there the most important were
like years now we
have other fights to fight which are
currently europe that's it with her
husband serge and blissful  klarsfeld has consistently tracked
down former nazis
throughout his life to
catch those responsible for
the holocaust so that they are brought
to justice
this
holocaust remembrance day marks the anniversary of the
camp's liberation  'auschwitz 27
january 1945 europe
these situations its member states these
citizens must face
antisemitism fight them the antidote is to
remember on the one hand and
look ahead
alongside anto  nio tajani and tony
blair blissful klarsfeld issues a
warning european peoples
may not have done so that
extremists can wants to take
power at that's what we want a
europe the far right where europe
democratic
[Music]